Hello everyone today,
a couple hours ago this channel hit 1000 subscribers and I just wanted to get on
and say thank you.
I'm very glad that you guys are liking is content and our offering own insights.
I appreciate the advice and participation and support that you guys have given
me throughout the road here.
It's definitely been an uphill road,
you know compared to the videos that I was making back in the thought of his
channel.
I think I've improved a lot.
I'm proud of that improvement and I'm going to keep trying to improve and I
think for now the best way to say thank you to you guys for viewing and
subscribing to fire of learning is to keep it all going with the content that
you guys came here for.
I don't want to rehash the same videos and ideas of the rest of youtube is
making,
I want this channel to be unique and awkward.
His own insights and opera depth and perspective,
which is lacking on Youtube,
which you guys seem to find interesting.
And then he insights or opinions or video requests if you guys have will
definitely help to that end as they have thus far.
You know,
definitely tell me what you guys want to see and I will oblige.
So stay tuned.
I've got some interesting stuff coming and thank you all again for subscribing,
supporting me and watching fire of learning.
I will definitely do my best to make your subscription worthwhile and I'm fully
confident or we can go far with this channel.